sans transition demain un film qui sort
sur les écrans bonjour l'angoissé un
film très drôle les occasions de rire ne
sont pas si fréquentes réalisateur
pierre sueur voit si souvent dernier à
la télé qu'on oublie que son vrai métier
sa passion profonde c'est justement le
cinéma à la fiche de ce film ce héros
arditi et guy marchand rien que des
bouts présentation du film michel pascal
le héros de cette histoire est un cadre
moyennement supérieur qui travaille dans
une grande entreprise
c'est un homme modeste timide mais
toujours prêt à rendre service ni chaud
et un est un homme intelligent gentil
tendre mais qui vit complètement
recroquevillée dans sa coquille
parce que il a du mal à s'exprimer il a
du mal à briller en société alors qu'il
en a toutes les possibilités et au
travers de ce fait divers auxquels il va
être mêlé il va sortir de sa coquille
il va devenir un autre michaud en une
semaine
le bonhomme va être un autre dira plus
bonjour l'angoissé mes adieux langues et
pour la quatrième fois consécutive
pierre tchernia fait appel à son acteur
fétiche le héros du viager et des
gaspards michaud c'est michel serrault
employés de la société de protection
stop alarme
c'est l'indestructible s'occupe des
installations sonores et cherche depuis
longtemps une alarme minuscule on la met
en marché
la place d'un objet non oui bon
fonctionnement continu très précis parce
qu'il connaît bien sûr mon fils mais
c'est exactement où il veut aller
alors ça c'est formidable parce qu'en
même temps rooney la liberté puis cette
espèce de d'assurance en se disant lui
va se débrouiller avec ça il sait
exactement qui nous met sur des rails et
puis on vit le voilà qui je comprends
bien vous pouvez nous annonce
aujourd'hui vous allez en faire un
cinquième ensemble
soquem un sixième septième et en
huitième lavery d'armement de projets ce
qui nous manque c'est l'argent comme
d'habitude mais enfin on n'est pas
manchot sait faire la quête
voilà